اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن امرا
تنفيذيا يوسع من سلطات ادارته في اصدار
عقوبات ضد المسؤولين عن تهديد السلام
والامن والاستقرار في السودان ومن يقودون
الانتقال الديمقراطي في البلاد واشدد
الرئيس الامريكي على ضروره التوصل لوقف
دائم لاطلاق النار ووضع حد للعنف العسكري
والسماحي بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه دون
عوائق
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما هي ابعاد وصول البيت الابيض الى
هذه المرحله في تعامله مع الاوضاعف
السودان وما الذي سينبني عن اعلان الرئيس
بايدن من اجراءات عمليه على الارض كيف
سيتعامل طرف الصراع في السودان مع هذا
التوجه الامريكي وهل فيهما سيدفع بهما الى
الحوار لانهاء القتال اما ان العكس قد
يحصل ما هي الخطوات والخيارات الاخرى
المتاحه للاداره الامريكيه والمجتمع
الدولي مستقبلا لتمكين جهود احلال السلام
بالنظر الى التعقيدات الداخليه والخارجيه
التي تؤثر في المشهد السوداني
[موسيقى]
اهو منعرج عملي في الموقف الامريكي من
التطورات الداميه في السودان ام انه تلويح
بورقه العقوبات عساها تدفع طرفي المواجهه
من جيش وقوات دعم سريع للجلوس الى طاوله
الحوار وانهاء الخلاف بينهما سلميا الجميع
يتحدث عن السلام لكن لا احد استطاع فرض
نقطه انطلاق نحوه عدا هشه تتهددها
الخروقات كل حين بل واكثر من ذلك ما قالته
مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكيه ايفر
الهينز خلال افادتها امام لجنه القوات
المسلحه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي حيث قالت
ان طرفي الصراع في السودان يسعيان الى
الدعم الخارجي في سياق رهان كل منهما على
الحاق الهزيمه بالاخر نتابع جانبا مما
قالته
تقديرنا ان القتال في السودان بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع من
المحتمل ان يستمر لان كلا الجانبين
يعتقدان ان بامكانهم الانتصار عسكريا وان
لديهما القليل من الحوافز للجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات يسعى كلا الجانبين الى
مصادر خارجيه للدعم وهذا الامر في حال نجح
فمن المرجح ان يزيد من حده الصراع ويخلق
احتماليه اكبر لانتشار التحديات في
المنطقه كما ان القتال ادى الى تفاقم
الاوضاع الانسانيه المترديه في السودان ما
اجبر منظمات الاغاثه على تقليص عملياتها
[موسيقى]
الموضوع مع ضيفينا من واشنطن الدكتور كامل
هاتسون مستشار المبعوثه الامريكي السابق
الى السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق
في البيت الابيض ومن الدوحه السيد عادل
الباز الكاتب الصحفي ورئيس تحرير صحيفه
الاحداث السودانيه مرحبا بكما
ماذا قرات بين سطور بيان الرئيس جو بايدن
فيما يتعلق بالسودان
انه تحرك ايجابي من منظوري السياسه
الامريكيه اذا ما قرانا الاعلان بالتمعن
هو مؤشر وبيان حول ماهيه السياسه
الامريكيه ويشير الى انقلاب
[موسيقى]
وايضا يشير الى احتمال ان يكون من دعمه
ذلك الانقلاب معرضين لعقوبات وايضا الذين
لا يزعزعون الاستقرار الان اضافه الى من
قد يحاول تقويض العمليه السياسيه التي
تؤدي الى حكم مدني في المستقبل اذا انه
اعلان ينظر الى الوراء الى الماضي كما
يتطلع الى المستقبل ويشير الى القتال
الحالي على الارض كل هذا
او يجعل هذا الاعلان اداه مهمه لكن يجب ان
يفهم الجميع ان هذا الاعلان لم يتضمن ايه
عقوبات على اي حد هو عباره عن تشكيل او
صياغه لاداه قانونيه جديده في حوزه
الاداره الامريكي اذا ما شاءت استخدامها
لكن لا توجد اي ضمانات بان اي افراد اشخاص
او مؤسسات قد يخضعون العقوبات فعلا
وتتذكرون قبل عامين
الاداره اداره بايدن
اتخذت خطوه مشابهه حول اثيوبيا وقتل
كثيرون لكن القانون لم يستخدم ابدا لفرض
ايه عقوبات على اي حد لذا انا يساورني
الشك واعتقد ان هذا هو مجرد تكتيك لاظهار
انهم يتعاملون بجديه وتهديد لكن حتى اتخاذ
خطوه عمليه لا اعتقد اننا يمكن ان نعتبره
رد فعل ولا اعتقد ان كثيرين سيعبهون كثيرا
بهذا الاعلان اليوم
هل يوصف بيان الرئيس جو بايدن الواقع
فعليا على الارض في السودان
اعتقد ان هذا البيان جاء بعد التطورات
الحصى الحدث الان في الارض
هذا البيان اذا تاخر كثيرا يتحدث عن
1921 حينما حدث الانقلاب ولا يتحدث عن
التطورات الحاليه حينما حدثت هنالك التمرد
لم تتعرض له الاداره الامريكيه بالادانه
او تتعرض اليه باي نوع من انواع
التصريحات هنالك تصريحات من الاداره
الامريكيه قبل 72 ساعه اعتبرت ان هذا شان
داخلي ودعت الدول التي تتدخل فيه ثم عاده
الان ترفع
يدها بالتحديد بالعقوبات والقرارات ولذلك
انا اعتقد الاداره الامريكيه الان هي تخوض
ايضا في مبادره مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه صحيح هنالك تخبط الان في الموقف
الامريكي ماذا تريد امريكا بالضبط او ما
هو موقفها الحقيقي من الاوضاع في السودان
يعني مجرد ادانه التمرد لم لم تحدث نزاع
داخلي شاني داخلي اصبح يهدد الامن القومي
الامريكي كيف لا احد يعلم يعني افريقيا
هذه
تفيض بالسرعات المسلحه والتمردات ولم نسمع
عن اي منها اصبح هو مهدد الامن القومي
الامريكي ولذلك السياسه الامريكيه بهذا
الشان سياسه مربكه ولا تستطيع ان تغرى الى
اين تتيه هل هي تهديد العقوبات فقط ام
فعلا تزعا الى دعم لطرف من الاطراف تجعر
ان موظفه في
الميدان تضعضع واصبح اغرب الى الهزيمه هذه
الاشكالات لا توضح السياسه الامريكيه انت
تلوح سيد عادل عفوا انت تلوح بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحاول دعم قوات الدعم
السريع لان موقفها على الارض
سالنا عن توقيت اصدار هذا البيان توقيت
مريب فعلا قبل 72 ساعه كان هذا كان
الداخلين اليوم وكان يهدد القوم الامن
القومي الامريكي
هذه النقطه من الدكتور هاتسن دكتور هل هل
قرات في البيان ما يدعم فعليا طرف على اخر
كما يقول سيد عادل
لا ارى ذلك في هذا البيان واعتقد ان
الراتب المتحده في بياناتها الاخرى قد
حملت المسؤوليه على كلا الطرفين عن العنف
وكذا طرفين اعتذرا مسؤولين عن الانقلاب
وانهيار المحادثات التي تمت قبل اسابيع
لكن مع استمرار القتال على الاتحاد سيكون
من الصعوبه بمكان للولايات المتحده ان
تتعامل معكره طرفين بنفس الشاكره نرى
تقارير من الارض من السودان يوميا تشير
الى ان قوات الدعم السريع تستهدف المدنيين
وترتكب الجرائم جنسيه ضد النساء ويجندون
الاطفال كمقاتلين
ويدمرون البنت تحتيه مثل المستشفيات هم
يستهدفون المدنيين في
السيد عادل تساءل كيف لهذا ان يهدد الامن
القومي الامريكي والسياسه الخارجيه يعني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المنهمكه في
شرق اسيا في الصين في حرب اوكرانيا كيف
لما يحدث الان على الارض بان يهدد الامن
القومي الامريكي والسياسه الخارجيه هل لك
ان توضح لنا اذا كان لديك صوره عن الموضوع
اعتقد ان واشنطن ليست جديده في تعاملها مع
السودان فقط استثمرت واشنطن دبلوماسيا
لاكثر من عشرين عاما الان استثمرت في
مساله دارفور وفي مساء الاخرى وانفصال
جنوب السودان اذا
السودان عفوا لا المتحده عرفت الاستقرار
في القرن الافريقي في السودان وفي بقيه
ناصر كمحل اهتمام من مشاغل الامن الامريكي
اذا لا يمكن ان نقول ان هذا الامر جديد
لكن ما يوضحها البيان هو ان من مصلحته
ان تكون هناك حكومه مدنيه تتولى زمامه
الامور في السودان لانه بذلك ستحول دون
تدخل
مباشر
تحول دون التدخل ارهابيين سوف تقلل من
الاتجار بالبشر تجاه ليبيا والبحر المتوسط
اذا هناك اسباب متعدده وراء الشعور واشنطن
من مصلحتها ان تكون هناك حكومه مدنيه في
السودان هذه نقطه مهمه سيد عادل وفعلا
البيت الابيض بيانات البيت الابيض تصريحات
وزير خارجيه الامريكي دائما تشدد على
ضروره الانتقال السلمي للسلطه الى حكومه
مدنيه كيف ترون هذا في كل خطابات وتصريحات
البيت الابيض في في ظل الصراع القائم الان
وغياب المكونه المدني تماما عن المشهد انا
اعتقد ان هذه هي اسره الازمه
المكون
امريكا تطلب مواصفات معينه للحاجه الحكومه
المدنيه وتدعم اطراف في الصراع السياسي
داخل السودان وكونت
ثم بالرباعيه اربع دول هي التي
تتعامل مع مكون مدني محدد
لتفرض واقع سياسي محدد وقد كان غد
تم الاتفاق او تم توقيعها الاتفاق الاطاري
ومجموعه محدده من الاحزاب السياسيه
وهذه هي التي فجرت الازمه وخلقت الازمه ان
امريكا تنحاز الى
محدد اطراف كبرى في الساحه السياسيه احزاب
وكيانات كلها عزلت من العمليه السياسيه
وهذا ما جعل الاجواء متوتره
وادت الى الى هذا التوتر الى التوتر بين
المكونات العسكريه الدعم السريع
والجيش وهذا الدال لتبذير الحرب ولذلك
غالبا التدخلات الامريكيه وانحيازاتها
بالساحه السياسيه السودانيه ظلت على
الدوام تسير ازمات تسير مشاكل داخل
السودان يريد موضوعنا السيد عادل ولكن
لماذا تحمل الاطراف المدنيه الصراع القائم
الان بين حماتي والبرهان
هو هو الذي فجر هذا الصراع بسبب انه
الاتفاق الايطالي اقصر مجموعات كبيره جدا
داخل المجتمع السوداني من المشاركه
وجود جيشين في الدوله الجيش السوداني لم
يقبل هذه الفكره وظل يتحدث عن ضروره دمج
القوات المسلحه دمج الدعم السريع في
القوات المسلحه الاطراف الدوليه كلها من
ضمنها البعثه كانت تتحدث عمولا خمسه الى
عشره سنوات لدمج هذه القوات والجيش
السوداني لم يقبل هذا هذه الفكره واثقها
الى توتر في الساحه السياسيه ادى الى هذا
الانفجار طيب
اردنا ان نتحدث بالادوات السيد كوربي قبل
قليل قال بان الامر التنفيذي للرئيس جو
بايدن يتيح لوزاره الخزانه
الوضع بشان فرض عقوبه متعلقه بالنزاع في
السودان ما امكانيه فرض عقوبات يعني لا
احد يعتقد بان السيد برهان او السيد حميد
لديهم مصالح او اموال ربما في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لفرد عقوبات عليهم ما
هي الادوات المتحده الامريكيه اذا كانت
تريد فعلا ان تضغط
لحث الاطراف على الجلوس لطاوله الحوار من
بوابه العقوبات هل هي
الوسيله الناجعه لوقفه اطلاق النار
بتقديرك
اعتقد انما تحاول تنعمل له من خلال هذا
الاعلان انها تضع على الطاوله عمليه
اجرائيه اليوم اولا وحذروا بامكانيه فرض
العقوبات اعتقد انها تتطلع لرؤيه هل ان
احدا من الجنرى لانه كليهما سيغير من
سلوكه او لا لكن
العقوبات قد تستهدف المحيطين بهما ان لم
يكن هما شخصيا لهذا هنا هم مثلا
قد يرفضون عقوبات على محمد العطف الجنوب
او اخوه
الفريق حمدته قد تصدف واشنطن اشخاص من
المقربين وتتركوا الى النهايه استهداف
القاده انفسهم اعتقد ان من المهم تذكر ان
كل العقوبات التي صدرت حول السودان لم يكن
هناك عقوبات ضد الرئيس البشير لانه كان
هناك حاجه اليه للتفاوض معه ورغم سوء
العلاقه معه لكننا لم نفرض عقوبات شخصيه
كل العقوبات على نظام السوري لم تغير من
الصراع بشكل ايجابي بل زادت حده التوتر
وايضا التدخلات الخارجيه
اذا على ماذا تعول الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه باقتضاض لو سمحت
انه وعشان تراهن على حقيقه ان الجمرات
سيشعرون بالخوف خاصه الجدران الحمضتي لان
موارده الشخصيه هو يستخدمها لشراء السلاح
وتجنيدها المقاتلين اذا كانت هناك عقوبات
ضده شخصيا وشبكته
وشركاته وحساباته ليس فقط في السودان ولكن
المتحده لكن في دبي وفيها اماكن اخرى كل
ذلك سيحد من قدرته على شان الحرب وسيصعب
عليه امكانيه انفاق ماله على الحرب وربما
سوف يؤدي الى نهايته بوقت اسرع سيد عادل
هل سيغير اي من الجنرلين
سلوكاته جراء هذا المنعرج في السياسه
والتقييم الامريكي للوضع في السودان
انا اعتقد ان هذه العقوبات اذا فرضت لن
تغير اي شيء على ارض الواقع ظل السودان
اكثر من 30 عام تحت العقوبات الان امريكا
بعد التغيير التي تنادي الان بنظام مدني
وديمقراطي حينما قامت احنا بدات تغيير في
2019 امريكا لم ترفع العقوبات عن السودان
بل زادت العقوبات واضطرت السودان ان يدفع
من مواليده الصحيحه 400 مليون دولار مما
زاد الوضع الاقتصادي سوءا وللان حتى هذه
اللحظه العقوبات الامريكيه لم ترفع
فامريكا تقول انها تريد الحكومه
الديمقراطيه المدنيه وانها مستعده
لمساعدتها ولم تساعدها خلال فتره ما بعد
التغيير ولذلك العقوبات لم تعد تهدد احدا
في السودان العقوبات ظلت ترفع كشعار
ولم توضع في يوم من الايام على غايه من من
فعليا والسودان
القرارات الامميه والقرارات الامريكيه
يعني فاضت في السودان
وادت الى تدهور الوضع الاقتصادي ولكن لم
يستجيب لها احد انا هناك مثل في السودان
يقول انه يعني التمساح مهددوه بالغرق
السودان مليلي بالعقوبات مليب المشاكل
العقوبات الامريكيه لن تفعل اي شيء الان
في هذا الوضع الان الوضع الانساني يعني
حتى الوضع الانساني
الامم المتحده تطلب مليار دولار ونصف كل
الذي وصل حتى الان 200 مليون دولار وكل
وعود ولذلك حتى في هذه
ما يحتاجه السودان من المجتمع الدولي لن
يجده واذا وجد وجد الفتات وهناك تلويح
بعقوبات وكل هذه الاجراءات يعني انا اعتقد
ان
هنالك خطا في سياده الامريكيه
السودان طالما داوود من من فتره طويله جدا
لم تنجح سياسات الامريكيه في السودان
وتؤدي دائما الى ازمات وكوارث مستمره ادت
الى فرصه الجنوب وقامت حرب في الجنوب ادت
الى تغيير في السودان اصبح الوضع الان في
حرب في السودان كل الخطوات كل السياسات
التي تتخذها امريكا هي تودي الى اوضاع
اسوا مما كانت ربما ساسال لاحقا عن
الخيارات
يبدو السيد هاتسن لا يسمعنا سنعود اليه
فور اعاده التواصل معه طيب
السيده ايفر الهينز سيد عادل ابقى معك
مديره المخابرات الوطنيه اشارت الى
استقواء كل طرف بالخارج ومحاوله الحصول
على دعم من الخارج وبان هذا سيطيل الامد
الصراع في السودان ما انعكاسات هذا الواقع
واعتقاد كل طرف بانه يستطيع الحسم عسكريا
كما على اي جهود
لوساطه او للوصول الى الجلوس على طاوله
مفاوضات وان كان بممثلين عن الجنرلين انا
اعتقد ان
امريكا في هذا ايضا محيره امريكا الان
تقود مبادره مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لانهاء هذا
القتال
فايطاله الصراع بتشجيع طرف من الاطراف
الان هنالك عمليه تمرد داخل داخل الجيش
السوداني هذا التمرد ينبغي ان يلغي ان يجد
ادانا من كافه الدول من امريكا
بتشجيع هذا التمرد وايجاز المبررات
والالتفاف على ادانته بشعارات لا للحرب
وغيرها هذا هو ما يتيل ما يطيل
اذا لم نستهدف يعني يتحدث البيان عن ان
ذلك خيانه للعمليه السياسيه والعمليه
الديمقراطيه فينبغي تحديدا الخائن وايقافه
عن عن عن خيانته طيب
اعتقد ان
السيده ابريل
ترى ان هناك يعني استعانه باطراف خارجيه
الان الذي يستعين بطرف خارجي معلوم
وبدات بدات الحديث عن دعومات خارجيه
وارسال اسلحه وارسال
وتشوينات من الخارج الجيش السوداني لا
يحتاج الى اي دعم من الخارجي
يتلقى دعما خارجيا اسمع رايي الدكتور
نتحدث لان فقدنا الاتصال معك نتحدث عن
مقالته السيده ايفر الهينز بان كل طرف
يحاول الحصول على دعم خارجي وبنى هذا
سيطيل امد الصراع لان كل طرف يعتقد بانه
قادر الحسم هذه نظره تشاؤميه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
لماس ما يحصل الان وما سيحصل في السودان
اكيد انه اشاره اشاره على التشاؤم لكن
ايضا تفسير واقعي هذا هو تفسيري للموقف
طالما انك كلا من الطرفين يرى انه قادر
على حسم المعركه وانه لن ينجح ولن يبقى
على قيد الحياه السياسيا اذا بقي الطرف
الاخر حيا ايضا ولم ينتهي اعتقد انه لا
يبقى مجال كبير للتفاوض راينا انه على مدى
ثلاث ثلاثه اسابيع كان هناك مازق في
القتال بعض الاحياء والمواقع يتبادل كذا
الطرفين السيطره عليها لكن لم يمتلك اي
طرف مزيه تحقيق النصر الكبير على الطرف
الاخر لكن ما هو مهم هو التدخل اطراف
خارجيه سواء
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج مورا
الخبر شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى
اللقاء بامن الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]